hello everyone and welcome back to
versus i'm your host mark ellis and i'm
well aware that you can quench your
competitive thirst anywhere thanks for
making us your home or uh clicking on
this did by accident however you got
here land sea or air it's a good day to
honor four amazing performers while
acknowledging pride month we here at
rotten tomatoes celebrate our friends in
the lgbtq plus community every week of
the year and today we spotlight tessa
thompson aubry plaza janelle monae and
sarah paulsen in one corner we have
tessa known for universes like the mcu
film franchises like creed and freaky
cool tv series like westworld in the
next corner it's aubrey who skyrocketed
to fame on the hit show parks and rec
then made a splash on the big screen in
movies like safety not guaranteed and
black bear in the next corner it's
janelle monae who can literally do it
all act sing dance she's probably good
at video games she's been nominated for
grammys won billboard music awards and
starred in everything from hidden
figures to moonlight and finally in the
other other other corner it's sarah
paulson the american horror story deity
who's been in big time talkies like
ocean's 8 and glass the good news here
is that we get to celebrate them all by
taking an in-depth look at their careers
milestones and special achievements and
as is our custom here on versus how do
we honor talented folks well we make
them duke it out and then i get to
declare one the victor but you're all
getting a trophy and a pizza party after
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two ratings
round three tomato meter slash audience
score round four iconic characters and
then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve anything from the people
they've played to the music they
performed to who has personally met the
incredible hulk okay that one might be a
little one-sided but we'll come up with
something fair
please much like indiana jones i'm
making this up as i go along but henry
jr isn't a real person right he's not
yeah he's not a real person today we
have four of the most talented
non-fiction people in hollywood and
although none of them will be appearing
here in person despite my repeated
offers to validate their parking it's
exciting nonetheless they're all winners
in my book but only one shall emerge
victorious and gain entry into that most
prestigious club champion of versus we
should hand out jackets for this we'll
ideate that later in the meantime let's
get it on round one box office ah the
movies we show up grab our snacks i'm a
popcorn and diet soda man and when the
lights go down we're dazzled delighted
and swept up in a world of pure
imagination especially when said film
features janelle monae sarah paulson
aubry plaza or tessa thompson it's
thompson who's the odds-on favorite in
this round because of that little
cinematic universe from those comic
picture books in fact tessa is the only
one of our four competitors that can
boast about having a billion dollar
grosser on the resume well avengers end
game was a billion dollar engine until
it became a two billion dollar muscle
car settling in at just shy of 2.8
billion dollars worldwide that kids is
what you call a head start
that's funny but it's not just the mcu
that gives tessa a boost she also has
men in black international and creed 2
both of which hauled in over 200 million
bucks each around the globe the first
creed raked in 173 million dollars and
even the lower budget independent films
like sorry to bother you and selma
turned a nice profit all told thompson's
career total box office is an
astonishing
4.46 billion dollars worldwide with a
perfect average of 446 million sure
avengers and thor ragnarok's 850 million
dollars do the heavy lifting but
valkyrie kicks a ton of ass in those
movies and i'd pay to see more aubry
plaza is also part of a giant movie
machine you ever hear a pixar those
movies make scrooge mcduck numbers and
her turn in monsters university sets the
high bar for her multiplex receipts to
the tune of 743 million little kid
screams i mean uh dollars yeah dollars
that's good enough to propel her career
earnings to over a billion bucks
bolstered by solid comedy profits from
funny people at 71 million dollars mike
and dave need wedding dates at 75
million and her only other film that
took in over 100 million dollars you
guessed it dirty grandpa with 105
million hey whatever it takes to get an
88 million dollar per film average am i
right i like funny people that is my
answer to whatever question you're
asking give me a break i don't even know
you onward to janelle monae who also
struck gold with an animated hit rio 2
and it's 492 million total that bird is
one rich macaw it's a macaw right
there's a macaw in the movie although
monel has the shortest filmography in
the field today it still packs a punch
janelle's career box office total is 882
million dollars making for a sterling
126 million per movie average that's
thanks in large part to hidden figures
the biographical smash hit that earned
231 million dollars on the big screen
more biopic success was found with
2019's harriet and its 44 million dollar
take and then we tack on moonlight which
landed its way to a 65 million run if
you're keeping score at home tessa
thompson has a sizable lead over both
janelle monae and aubry plaza but what's
that good god that's sarah paulson's
the music is escaping healthy she's been
a force of the box office since the turn
of the millennium and it's still 2 000's
what women want that tops the paulson
resume punching in at 374 million
dollars she then saw bigger roles in
success stories like ocean's eight and
glass each of which took in over 200
million dollars on the silver screen
paulson's diverse imdb also includes the
post at 179 million dollars 12 years of
slave at 180 million and the animated
hits keep on choogling abominable yeti
its way to 188 million dollars in 2019.
paulson was also one of the
approximately 38 000 famous people in
the movie new year's eve but today we'll
say that sarah and john bon jovi were
the two leads it made 146 million
dollars because well it's a very popular
holiday there's a lot of good college
football games on that day too paulson's
per film average is 113 million dollars
extracted from her total talking picture
career hall of 1.81 billion dollars all
right so let's do some quick math here
tessa thompson remains dominant the
franchise boost is real as is the
credibility that thompson lends to
projects that want to be taken seriously
we could actually combine the numbers of
janelle aubrey and sarah and they still
wouldn't match the output of tessa
thompson that's a win in round number
one and tessa goes up one to nothing to
nothing to nothing
round two ratings
if you're a returning customer here at
versus welcome back you're probably
freaking out because round two is always
the tomato meter round right well okay
relax don't panic you're not losing your
mind but i also can't justify lumping
all of the great tv work these four
talents have given us into some box
office round this isn't tom hanks
starting off in bosom buddies or that
time bruce willis was on friends no this
is sarah fricken paulson and that's
american horror story over 3 million
humans tuned in to check out the first
ahs episode and since the anthology
series has regularly averaged around 1.6
million viewers each week even more
impressive is that it's been on for 10
seasons and paulson has starred in 96
episodes and speaking of america
american crime story has also made a
splash thanks to sarah contributing to
20 of those hours paulson also won rave
reviews for the netflix hit ratchet we
actually don't have much info on the
exact amount of views that gets because
netflix ratings are kind of like the
skull secret society
we'll just have to believe them when
they say 48 million people watched bird
box janelle monae's recently had a very
successful entry into the smaller but
still 85 inches big screen homecoming
has two seasons on amazon prime the same
streaming service where you can enjoy
the comedy special sensation dog
stepfather
thank you jesus but while janelle's tv
resume may not be as robust as paulson's
just yet the same cannot be said for
aubry plaza or tessa thompson tessa is a
revelation on westworld and the hit hbo
show that's absolutely bonkers has made
good on the promising talent that was
thompson on earlier shows like veronica
mars and copper hey remember that movie
legion yeah it's also a show on fx
created by noah howie and it also
features aubrey plaza see i had a point
i was getting to well received the
legion may be we'll find out in the next
round twas parks and rec that got
plaza's star on the rise the show ran
from 2009 to 2015 is constantly the
source of hopeful rumors that it will
somehow someway come back and aubrey
starred in 123 episodes but if it feels
like this could be another overwhelming
victory for one competitor just like
round one that's because it is sarah
paulson has been a force on the cable
box since before streaming was the thing
back then people were fly fishing in
actual streams while sarah was enjoying
success in shows like american gothic
deadwood and jack and jill which based
on my research has nothing to do with
the movie jack and jill the show is out
first and uh yeah i can't think about
that movie anymore i've never looked at
out pacino the same way since you don't
understand what i want to understand you
don't understand paulson may have heard
the footsteps of folks like aubrey plaza
and tessa thompson but in the end mrs
america is just too strong oh that's
another show she's on from 2020. the
point in round two goes to nurse ratchet
she was just misunderstood tessa and
sarah are tied at one and janelle and
aubry are looking to get on the board as
we head to
round three tomato meter slash audience
score there it is our old pal is the
tomato meter and the audience scored two
beloved metrics that act as an aggregate
of how a wide swath of the world's
finest critics and fans feel about a
particular project unfortunately for
janelle monae we don't yet have a tomato
meter metric for music but you gotta
think dirty computer would be like 96
certified fresh if we did thank you for
being here luckily for monet movies and
tv shows do count and she's got some a
quality work to brag about kicking off
with moonlight and it's well deserved 98
on the tomato meter hidden figures is
also scholarship worthy at 93 percent
and harriet is at 73
interestingly enough harriet and
moonlight basically flip-flop once we
get to the audience score side of the
equation harriet is the big winner at 97
percent moonlight holds its own at 79
and even though monet has some rotten
flicks like antebellum at 30 and welcome
to marwin at 34 overall janelle has a
fresh average of 60 on the tomato meter
and 64 on the audience score up next is
sarah paulson who will once again be
leaning on her television success to get
a lead taking w in this round american
horror story is fresh at 77 american
crime story is even better smelling at
84 and remember when i brought up mrs
america
come on not the contest the show
starring sarah paulson and probably not
steve harvey yeah it's a positively rosy
96 percent sarah has some big screen
winners too like mud at 97 percent 12
years a slave at 95 percent and the post
at 88 percent more freshness can be
found with abominable at 82 percent
serenity hey she's in that is also at 82
percent and bird box is 64 oh right
she's also in that movie that was
apparently watched by 580 million people
within the first three hours of release
maybe we'll never know
but sometimes getting lots of work can
hamper one's tomato meter average i did
give her flowers for the box office take
of new year's eve which despite having
jon bon jovi in it only notched seven
percent on the tomato meter which is the
lowest film of any competitor in the
match today dirty grandpa
congratulations you're not the worst
movie of the bunch oh man i don't know
that paulson is just about even with
janelle monae as sarah sports a
tie-making 60 average on the tomato
meter and 61 percent with the audience
okay aubry plaza let's rip this dirty
grandpa band-aid off yikes it is at 10
percent play professional across europe
but again not the worst from there it's
mostly good news for plaza as she has
safety not guaranteed at 91 percent
black bear at 90
and ingrid goes west at 85 props are
also in order for scott pilgrim versus
the world at 82 percent funny people at
the bill and ted approved 69
and child's play notching 64
well done chuck yay for some odd reason
the audience score isn't quite as kind
to plaza scott pilgrim is the
breadwinner here but only at 84 percent
movies like child's play and funny
people fall into rottenness on this side
of the tracks but don't worry dirty
grandpa makes a rousing comeback and is
all the way up to 44 well done you
filthy wrinkly bastard 105 million
dollars
you're looking for some extra credit
plus this average remains competitive as
aubry has the high mark for the tomato
meter so far at 62 percent and the low
number with the audience at 52 finally
we have tessa thompson entering the
arena and with tessa comes a whole lot
of mcu lumber
avengers end game is at 94 percent thor
ragnarok is 93
and those flicks aren't even in
thompson's top three according to the
tomato meter selma is 99 fresh little
woods is 95 and crete is also at 95
these are ivy league quality marks we're
getting here where's creed 2 you ask
well the greatest movie of all time is
at 83 percent tying it with the other
greatest movie of all time return of the
jedi see b minus grades are all you need
i'll also point out that thompson's role
opposite ruth nega in passing is at 90
percent and probably got snubbed at a
certain awards ceremony and even with
men in black international's 23
and the 2006 iteration when a stranger
calls it 9
thompson still has the best tomato meter
average of the bunch with 70 per outing
and it's a tie at the top between tessa
and janelle monae at 64 for the audience
score which means in the first really
tightly contested round of the day tessa
thompson gets another point she goes up
two to sarah paulson's one to zero to
zero and two rounds remain to determine
a winner so will karine write in too
round four iconic characters and now we
arrive at the round that will reward
those who made their mark on any screen
by turning in a memorable performance
that shouldn't be forgotten luckily for
all of us each one of our four stars
today has plenty of ammo when it comes
to dynamic character work that stays
with us long after we leave the theater
or go in the other room i guess if
you're watching it on tv i don't have a
tv in every one of my many rooms i don't
have a tv in the bedroom why it's not
because i can't afford it it's because
that is a palace of sleep and a fortress
of solitude speaking of superheroes no
we're not going to tessa thompson yet
what the hell are you talking about
let's start with some real life heroes
like mary jackson in hidden figures
played by janelle monae jackson was a
ground-breaking and barrier-shattering
mathematical genius who helped form a
crucial team without which we probably
never would have landed on the moon
monet also played mary buchanan
alongside cynthia revo's harriet tubman
in harriet and her turn in antebellum as
veronica slash eden alone makes me think
that that tomato meter score could be a
little low luckily there's a podcast
called rotten tomatoes is wrong that
some guy is on every week it's me i'm
the guy yeah no we're very happy for you
despite my love for hidden figures i'd
have to give moonlight the honor of
being my favorite monet film simply
because it's such an overpoweringly
emotional movie thanks to no small part
to janelle's character theresa it's a
crucial role because she's the one who
acts as a safe harbor when kyron needs
guidance as he discovers his own
sexuality without a nurturing mother
figure theresa acted as the mentor for
us the audience as well nurturing is
what you'd hoped to get from a nurse but
if that medical practitioner's last name
is ratched you may want to look
elsewhere
paulson stepping into the iconic
antagonist role from one flew over the
cuckoo's nest in the netflix prequel
gave so many more layers to the
character without diminishing any of the
anxiety we still feel from watching the
classic 70s film paulson can also go
deep undercover and be almost
unrecognizable as marcia clark the famed
prosecutor depicted in the o.j simpson
season of american crime story and as
captivatingly evil as paulson is in 12
years a slave i'll look to one of my
favorite parts of hers from american
horror story as the best in the
apocalypse season sarah is spot on
playing both the cordelia and the
wilhelmina characters it's not even in
my top five preferred horror story
seasons but digging deeper into a role
from coven and some very impressive
fashion choices left an impression on
this scary show enjoyer thanks to a
stirring debate sequence in dear white
people tessa thompson's samantha white
in that film is certainly one for the
books as is her wonderful supporter of
adonis creed's boxing dreams in the
creed franchise thompson makes the most
of her screen time opposite michael b
jordan and gets plenty of moments to
shine as a rising star in the music
scene but if you want an iconic role i
gotta go intergalactic and gush about
valkyrie it's not easy to hold your own
against the likes of thor loki and that
big green guy but tessa shined as the
new star in the mcu once ragnarok hit
theaters and thompson was one of the
most in-demand heroes by the time end
game closed the book on a few of our
other comic book pals here's hoping we
get lots more valkyrie before it's all
said and done which given how much money
these movies make it might be a while
this isn't over and finally we turn to
aubrey plaza whose resume is much more
packed than it might appear for someone
who struck gold at age 25 booking the
role of april on parks and rec since we
just did a versus featuring all the
olson sisters i'm very high on ingrid
goes west as the title character plaza
demonstrates a wealth of range on her
way out to cali to hopefully be bffs
with elizabeth olsen did elizabeth
defeat the olsen twins in that episode
of versus i'm not going to tell you here
you got to watch the episode and i'm
also not 100 sure if i remember who won
or even if i made the right call we do
this for fun yay i had a blast watching
aubry in the to-do list a coming-of-age
comedy that felt like a slightly less
sophomoric version of american pie but i
loved safety not guaranteed and she's so
believable as darius who might be
falling for mark duplace's kenneth just
in the nick of time wink wink as iconic
as so many characters from these four
talents are i keep finding myself drawn
back to the unique comedy timing of
aubry plaza tessa thompson certainly has
the marquee name roles sarah paulson is
stunningly transformative in the horror
stories from the united states and
janelle monae can be both full of
emotion and a rock for someone else at
the same time but plaza's early days
training on ucb stages continue to pay
off in the form of iconic roles that
move from quirky innocent to deliciously
devious much to scott pilgrim's chagrin
so what can i get you so in what might
be an upset pick i'm going aubrey plaza
in this round she gets on the board and
there's one round left to get a point
called
the wild card round take the fork
hungry as i may be when i authored this
video essay the moniker for this round
does not relate to the popular dining
instrument rather it's a quote i
borrowed from baseball legend and funny
talk king yogi bera vera said when you
come to a fork in the road take the fork
for our superstars today i imagine the
fork in the road would be between the
streets of movies and television so what
else you got or perhaps what's the most
interesting off the beaten path project
each of our competitors has taken on yes
i get to take loss of liberty with the
wild card round but given the careers
forged by this quartet so far we're
gonna need a golden corral-sized fork to
get it all in or better yet a ponderosa
steakhouse fork because that is the
establishment where janelle monae got
her very first job after clocking out of
the restaurant biz for the last shift
it's been up up and away not just in the
world of acting but also music that
might be the best utensil in the
proverbial kitchen that is monet's work
and this metaphor is getting away from
me so i'll just mention that her musical
abilities are so impressive they've
caught the ears of legends like prince
and monet has been nominated for a
grammy multiple times janelle also won
the billboard music award for rising
star in 2013 and the trailblazer award
in 2018. the arch android some knights
and dirty computer have all been hailed
as seminal records of the last 15 years
aubry plaza's fork might just be her
unique personality itself in fact she
landed the april role on parks and rec
in large part because she left such a
lasting impression after meeting with
co-creator michael sher according to
shurer aubry came over to my office and
made me feel really uncomfortable for
like an hour and immediately i wanted to
put her in the show so you see kids
don't try to fit in when you're at an
audition stand out for aubry plaza that
means just keep being you because it is
working i hate people sarah paulson's
road has been largely intertwined in the
last decade with ryan murphy the
showrunner for american horror and crime
stories that sounds like one show but if
you've been paying attention you know
it's two different programs and i'm just
lazy in paulson's words she referred to
their relationship as the creative
marriage of my life murphy will have an
idea and bring it to sarah first even
before ryan would talk it over with his
own husband and it's a testament to her
ability to disappear into a role that
she's been a recurring character in the
murphy anthologies sometimes we
recognize her many times we don't but
it's always a performance worth
remembering tessa thompson has proven to
be a performer worthy of greater
claimants to penned his box office and
those two compliments don't always go
hand in hand generally you're either
making huge movies or getting rave
reviews but she manages to pull off both
at the same time so as we look forward
to more big time popcorn stuffers like
creed 3 and thor love and thunder don't
forget the lessons we just learned with
passing tessa thompson is a threat to
earn a nomination every time she's on a
mark tessa got her start in the los
angeles theater circuit and ever since
has been a big advocate that the left
coast can more than hold its own against
the east and the broadway lights again
these are for the top stars working in
hollywood today but in a round that
rewards bold life decisions and new
career ventures i gotta go with janelle
monae for being able to do it all on the
lighted stage act sing dance monet is an
all-around performer who can be funny
and lighthearted then deeply
introspective sometimes in the same
scene or song janelle monae takes the
wild card and our final score is two to
one to one to one which means everyone
got on the board and tessa thompson is
the winner in a very well-played versus
match-up today no i didn't win
but at least i didn't make any new
friendships but it was really hard not
to lean towards janelle monae as i'm a
big fan of ponderosa steakhouse and
footlocker where she also worked before
getting her start because it'd be really
weird if she worked at foot locker after
she became a big star and sarah paulson
has given us hours and hours of
binge-worthy content and aubry plaza
studied at ucb where i too have a little
too much fun occasionally so i'm a fan
of all four none of them are hidden
figures anymore they're front and center
on this episode of versus tessa thompson
is your winner and i'm really happy i
didn't upset thor or adonis creed by
picking someone else that's all for this
edition of the show hit me up with your
take on social media at mark ellis live
and keep it right here at rotten
tomatoes for all the latest and greatest
in the world of movies tv and more i'm
mark ellis and i will never be a dirty
grandparent
[Music]
you